ما حقيقه الضجه التي اثيرت حول تصريحات
ميشيل الي ماري الوزيره الفرنسيه الشهيره
في تلك الفتره
وعلاقتها بالسلطه التونسيه انا ذاك فرنسيه
فرنسا الداخليه
في في هذه الاشياء هي فرنسا بالتالي
الاتصال بهمه او طلب ااا كيفاش يسموها
يعني
حاجه عاديه جدا
في ملاعب الكره القدم
في في في ملاعب كره القدم
تستهلك فيها الله كريم
بمساعده قوى الامن التونسيه بارسال قنابل
الدموع
في الثورات خاصه
الموقع
حتى وزير الخارجيه خلي اتصال بامكان ليه
في اطار العلاقات الثنائيه اكثر ولا اقل
وذلك التصريح وهو يهمه السيد كمال مرجان
تحدثها في هذا البرنامج
تطوير العلاقات
في تلك الفتره وفي تلك الفتره كانت عاديه
في مستوى عادي جدا همم
[موسيقى]
العلاقات مع الولايات المتحده كانت في
امور معينه خاصه
ايضا
العلاقه مع الولايات المتحده
اثارتها او اثاره
تركي همم
هذا تاشيره يعني اشياء احيانا خاصه
مذكرات سفيره ومراسلات سفيره الى خيريه
هذه بطبيعه الحال تثير عده اشياء وتغضب
اعطينا مثلا على امر بالضبط
[موسيقى]
ان الولايات المتحده لم تهنئ الرئيس
التونسي على اعاده انتخابه هذا لا اعرف
عنه
وزير الخارج
المرجان واجابكم على هذا لان انا لا اعرف
ذلك
اطراف
ولست انا من يتابع
تتلمس اذا ما كان لا لا ذلك او قد اثر على
العلاقه مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي
بعد الانتخابات وبعد مباشره او بعد معناها
همم في نوفمبر ظاهره حكايه ويكيليكس جاء
التهاني او من تاتي او لم تاتي لا ادري